when he first
called me and said look i have something
that i want to talk to you about it was
kind of an immediate yes
because
just knowing lynn it was like whatever
he's being drawn to whatever he wants to
create i know it's going to have certain
qualities i know it's going to be rich
it's going to be deep it's going to be
very heartfelt it's going to be complex
it's going to be intellectual it's going
to be moving it's going to be very funny
it's
it's going to be the full
story storytelling meal
[Music]
hi i'm andrew garfield and this is how i
became jonathan last
i learned really about jonathan larson
through lin-manuel miranda asking me to
play him in this film adaptation of his
one-man show that turned into a
three-person off-broadway show tick tick
boom that began called being called boho
days and it was just him
with a piano and his friend roger bart
doing backup vocals so for me it was
lynn really introducing me to john i
knew rent of course and i loved renting
the musical but it was a very
superficial relationship that i had with
john and i think i'm kind of grateful
for that in retrospect because it meant
i came into this
process of
becoming john and and deep diving into
who john was
in a way that didn't feel precious it
didn't feel like i was coming in with a
lot of baggage of the man the myth the
legend jonathan larson but actually i
was able to meet him in a more pure kind
of essential way i wanted to honor him
in the way that i think he would
actually wish to be honored which was
for all of his humanity all of his
messiness all of his ordinariness as
well as
this kind of extraordinary talent
um and and gift that he had and he gave
to the world and also all of his magic
because he was an incredibly magical
person but he was also an incredibly
human person as well so i'm indebted to
lin-manuel really for
introducing me to a long-lost brother
that i didn't realize
i had that's that's the kinship that i i
immediately started to feel when i
started to
unpick and uncover who john was
[Music]
hello
hi welcome
i'm jonathan larson he had me in mind to
play john and i was doing angels in
america on broadway at the time and he
basically said yes to doing a kind of
talk back q a with myself tony kushner
and the company but he had agreed to do
it to get close to me and i was like
that was a totally unnecessary elaborate
roundabout circumnavigation of a very
simple thing that all you had to do was
put out the call and i would show up and
then we had a lunch and he kind of he
slid you know jonathan larson's scoring
lyrics for tick tick boom across the
table to me at this sushi place in
midtown and he said this is not going to
make sense yet i promise you it will and
he kind of sold me
john and he kind of talked me through
the song why which is the song that i
sing in the delicate theater towards the
end of the film he kind of talked me
through that song and he was tearing up
and i was tearing up and i thought oh
dear it was immediately one of those
no-brainers like i want to work with you
i'm dying to work with you and then just
hanging with him i had to settle my
nervous system because you know he's
hamilton was on repeat in my iphone at
the time and it was like my playlist was
asking for a meeting it was like a crazy
thing and yeah we just kind of he just
kind of talked me through john and kind
of sold me john pitched me john and it
was like this this sounds like my my
brother and i i started to do my own
diving and i thought well if he wants me
to do this i'm doing it and even if i
don't know if i can sing or not or get
to the place of playing piano or not i'm
gonna commit because he said he wasn't
gonna shoot it within the year i thought
well that's enough time for me to see if
i can sing like if i can't sing within a
year then i you know i should give up i
work at the moon dance diner
okay one sec do we take reservations no
we do not take we're we're a diner never
played piano
sang
in the shower and karaoke
and and dancing is one of my favorite
things to do and never done it outside
of
on a dance floor to be a musical theater
actor to be a song and dance person has
always been something i've longed for
because like i had a very formal theater
training when i was 17 18 19 20. it
wasn't musical theater it was just
theater like you know studying classics
and modern playwriting but i didn't get
the opportunity to dive into
this other
area that maybe i was too scared to try
or didn't feel like i had a natural
propensity and talent for it was always
this kind of dream that was beyond
me being able to dream it into reality
until of course the dreamweaver arrives
who is lin-manuel miranda and so yeah so
i really took a year to get my chops up
and and worked with liz kaplan who's an
incredible vocal um singing teacher and
a couple of great piano teachers and
then lin's team as well and all this
cast everyone just kind of
held me and pushed me
deeper and deeper towards you know past
that fear of failure and the voice
cracking and making horrible sound and
in terms of becoming john it's like he
wasn't concerned how he sounded he was
just singing for his life and he was
singing for the lives of everyone around
him that was his way of giving healing
to the world into his community was
through his music was through his gift
and advocating for his community in that
regard so it was life and death for john
in all those ways so the singing was an
extension or an expression of or a kind
of like a soul cry to say we are here
and we we we want to just live my my
friends want to just live and i want to
just live and it's like that job on top
of the mountain thing it's like you
better hear me like we're here
and
let us be here and let us fulfill our
lives in the in the biggest way we can
possibly fulfill and that's what he was
singing for so the passion was much more
important than the sound but the sound
follows the passion so what if the
workshop happens and nothing changes
what then jonathan
maybe i'm just wasting my time do you
know how many jonathan larsons there are
one you know i think about
john being
36 and
and dying without having
received any of the harvest of his work
i think about vincent van gogh
i think about
the
[Music]
unquenchable desire that they must have
woken up with every morning
in the face of rejection being
misunderstood misperceived kind of
looked at as kooks insane people trying
to
revolutionize an art form in both their
cases and being kind of told to shut up
and still picking up the brush and still
sitting at the keyboard
there it is um this is a recreation of
john's
of john's um
apartment where he wrote and where he
played and
he still sat in that director's chair
and bashed it out surrendered to the
fact that he may never see it that's
what that is the struggle of all of all
of us of course i've had periods of that
in my life i think anyone who has lived
has that experience of like
you know having to
re-commit to a gift recommit to a
calling a vocation or a feeling of
destiny even no matter how foolish it
may feel no matter how afraid you are
that you're not going to be able to put
a roof over your head and get groceries
that is a rites of passage i think
especially for an artist a young artist
it's much easier to carry on when you
when you when you get told to carry on
by the world by your community by
you know
audiences whatever that is like that is
a gift that i'm never ever gonna take
for granted the fact that i get to be in
a space full of 1400 people every night
in terms of when we were doing angels in
america that was the capacity of our
theater and to have a an exchange and an
interchange with an audience
and for them to say
we for them to be quiet and silent
and to be in
a kind of silent dialogue with the
actors on stage that is the purest form
of what we're talking about in terms of
receiving
the kind of the energy and the
encouragement to continue he was getting
his energy and encouragement from
elsewhere from his friends from some
crazy divine theater god muse that knew
that he had rent inside him and that
knew that he wasn't gonna be here for a
long time and that knew he had to get
rent out before he passed so i it's
deeply mysterious and deeply beautiful
and yeah there's a strange thing where
you go man i'm li i'm lucky that i get
to
you know have my work reflected back to
me in a way that feels authentic that's
that's a gift that i'm not gonna take
for granted for sure
[Music]
sunday is a sequence that lin-manuel
lin-manuel miranda cooked up in honor of
john you know in honor of the fact that
this song that was a pastiche kind of
tongue-in-cheek ironic honoring of his
hero stephen sondheim that john had only
ever sung
solo at a piano with this one voice just
belting this number
so for lynn it was like he never got to
hear it
john never got to hear it with a court
with a choir so lynn was like um if he's
out there i'm going to make him hear it
and i'm going to fill
this
music these verses and chorus up with
this galaxy brained jonathan larson
choir of musical theater legends past
present and future even some musical
theater geniuses that he never got a
chance to see work and then people from
the rent company and then like his
heroes including bernadette peters and
andre the shields and brian stokes
mitchell and phoebe newerth so for lynn
it was like this is my way
of giving john his harvest and his
flowers the back row of the galaxy
wherever he is so that he can really
feel and hear it i found that really
moving and then on the day you know it's
like well we're in the middle of kovid
it was overwhelming but we got it in
little because none of the actors could
be together we had to plate it we had to
do it with lots of visual effects with
locked off shots so no actors got to
interact
so everyone was brought in
individually and plated into this into
each kind of shot which kind of was was
horrible but also at the same time it
meant that we could have sacred time
with each legend that came in so when
bernadette came in it was the bernadette
five hours
and then when bb came it was the bb5 out
like it was just like we got like so me
and lynn and the crew we got to just
have our like
little kind of like immersive theater
experience with each one of these kind
of genius people it felt like
like lin-manuel miranda's eighth
birthday party that and he invited all
the people that he would want there past
present and future alive or dead and
they all just they all came they all
came
and i have spent the last eight years of
my life writing he's getting out you're
gonna be rich and famous
and rewriting is exactly yet well i'm
getting so close
and rewriting can i hear it any day now
it was a strange thing because i did
have so long to prepare i had a year to
get myself
immersed and to add ingredients and to
kind of steep myself in all things john
larson to the point where i had the
luxury of showing up on set or showing
up in rehearsals and i could trust him
to move
i was just i and i would pray to him
every morning i would say you know hey
man
i will be your vessel i will be
your
you know container like let me help i
think my imagination and your
imagination is now intermingled enough
where i think i will be able to feel
when it's right so i'm gonna let go now
and i'm gonna get out of the way i'm
gonna carve a hole
in the ceiling and i'm gonna let you
come in and just get up man like just do
whatever the hell you want and that was
a really important thing to feel on this
on this particular film set was that
ability to be spontaneous that ability
to be impulsive and um
uncensored because john was that in life
he was always turned up to an 11 and he
wasn't he didn't stand on kind of social
kind of
agreements
he was a very irreverent
rebellious
radical kind of punk musical theater
rock kid and he was anti-establishment
and he was in he was the master of his
own life he made sure he was the master
of his own space and every space that he
went into whether it was the diner or
his own apartment or a rehearsal room
you know he would make an event out of
everything he wouldn't hold a party for
his friends he would hold a peasant's
feast you know like everything became a
thing
um and so for me it was really important
that i as andrew
jonathan felt that freedom to not be
concerned about where the camera was and
to trust the camera was going to be
following john and john he just took
over he like me and lynn would just let
him take over it was like what would
john do every morning that was the
question we would ask and i think
between us between myself and lynn
obviously who has such a deep connection
to john as well and his work and there
wouldn't maybe be a lin manuel miranda
musical theater maestro without take
take boom without jonathan larson and
what he did for musical theater and how
he lived so it was like this kind of
magical mystical spiritual thing
where he just started
governing everything he just started
moving through each scene
and all i had to do was kind of let him
at a certain point and you could feel it
when it happened there were certain
magical days and magical scenes and
magical songs where you were like oh
there yeah thanks thank you thank you we
didn't have to do anything he just
showed up
eight years
and the time keeps ticking
tick tick you need to ask are you
letting yourself be led by fear or by
love
fear a 100 fear i think the first song
where i really felt jon fully show up it
was y in the dela court and it was the
first song that we shot and it was live
singing and it's me at the piano just
kind of
improvising a song trying to meet this
impossibly emotional crux moment and
julie larson was on set with us that
night
his sister his wonderful sister and we
were just like
he just filled he filled that delicore
he filled me up and that vital moment of
meeting loss
meeting destiny of meeting calling and
of meeting the ephemeral short sacred
nature of life just kind of has to
happen in that song and you know i
prepared it and i created my choices and
my track but then i i had to go like
dude like i i this is too much for me to
just do on my own like you need to be
here and you need to tell me
you need to bring me through this and he
did and it was a stunning thing and then
we were in the diner doing the sunday
sequence and there was a moment that i
could not get 12 or 11 takes and i got
to this part every and every time i
would get to this lyric in the song i
would literally kind of like my body
would just crumble and i would kind of
just
i had like an allergic like i can't i
can't i don't know and i'm sorry can we
go again then was like sure he's never
seen me like this it was the one time
where i was just really really
struggling
and he was like he came in or i came out
i was like dude sorry can we talk he was
like yeah sure
and it and i was like i don't know how
to do this like john is not showing up
for this like what's going on he's like
well let's go for a walk and i'm like
well it's this moment
and like in the song and the way you've
created it i start singing about sunday
in the diner and i'm and the lyric is on
the soft
yellow purple red stools sit the fools
who should eat at home
like i'm dissing my patrons but i'm
looking at andre de shields and joel
gray and brian stokes mitchell and
cheetah rivera and beth malone and you
know bb new and i'm i'm looking at them
and i'm calling them fools this isn't
the way that jonathan wrote it man like
he wasn't imagining this thing that you
created he was like okay buddy i
understand
and i'm like how am i supposed to call
these people fools and he was like oh no
no no you don't know who they are they
are just patrons
and i'm like okay got it
and the only exception to that rule was
bernadette in that moment where we honor
bernadette otherwise the acting
adjustment was oh no you're not seeing
them this is for jonathan in the sky
this is not for jonathan and you right
now these are these are just happen to
be diner patrons that can sing really
well i'm like okay great fine you're
just and it's all in your imagination
dude i was like right right right yeah
they are just
people who look like those people who
have really and in my imagination they
have these beautiful musical theater
voices good done and then we got it in
the next take but yeah in that i think i
was really struggling because jonathan
wouldn't john was like i can't call them
fools can't call them fools can't call
themselves so we figured that out and
then we got to like actually honor
bernadette in that very very special way
which again was jonathan going i need to
we need to i can't treat her like a
patron she has to be
like this this moment doesn't exist
without her so we have to find a way of
honoring her
[Music]
so so far what's been so moving about
the response to the film has been of
course it's there's an overwhelming love
for it but the specific interactions
i've had with friends friends of friends
young artists really personal
interactions i've had where
they've said something along the lines
of this transcends a film for me this is
reminding me of
who i am actually god damn it like and
now i have to dust off my writing
equipment or i have to dust off the
guitar or the piano whatever that is
that
makes me come alive that i've buried or
i've been having doubts about
my calling and now i realize i have to
double down i have to go back and i have
to keep throwing it again i have no
choice i know that now thank you for the
reminder of that like a lot of young
young artists are having the same
experience that lin manuel had when he
saw this show off broadway when he was
21 22. he hadn't written in the heights
yet he hadn't he hadn't fully committed
to being a musical theater maker and the
way the story he tells is is exactly
what so many young artists are going
through right now with watching this
film and seeing this story play out in
the same way that lin did and lin it was
like it was a message and a bottle from
john going are you sure are you sure
this is what you want to do it might be
what you want to do but are you prepared
for it being this amount of rejection
this amount of failure you may lose
friends you may lose partners you may
not have any money you may be destitute
for decades you may never have your
creativity
seen or
honored or
reflected back to you you may never
receive your flowers do you still want
to do it
and
i think a lot of young artists and
actors and musicians and storytellers
are watching this film going
hell yes i have to and i know i i know i
when i saw the first cut that lynn
showed me of this i felt like i was
being transported back to being a 19
year old 20 year old acting student i
needed it that part of my psyche needed
that and to go oh no i have to do what i
have to do there's a thread that pulls
on us it's a very unique thread that we
all have that that we we if we if we let
go of we lose some of ourselves and i
think that's what this film is about and
it's it's encouraging us to not let go
of the thread
you